Exists.
It either works or it doesn't.
It really depends upon how much time and effort you,
you take working on yourself,
your act,
your perspective,
the way you deliver it.
We always had to win in Van Halen.
We had no choice.
We had to win the battle of the bands.
It was competitive.
We had to win over the club owner.
This was before there were dance system.
Cerwin Vega hadn't been,
hadn't figured out those base bins yet.
You had to have a live band,
five 45 minutes,
such a night place.
Was he a motherfucker closer song where you knew a band couldn't go on?
I have to.
You look the Grinch?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
we were pretty good at anything.
We had no development phase.
Mm.
Um,
I have tapes of us at the Hilton Hotel in Pasadena in 1973.
You would if I didn't tell Ya,
you know,
wouldn't,
you wouldn't think it was three years ago.
Kind of a sound.
There's virtually no development.
How'd that happen?
How did it work that way?
We had classical training.
Ah,
right.
And this kind of speaks to what we were discussing earlier in that a lot of my
colleagues are having a great time making music and they celebrate and it's uh,
the word fun comes into it.
And we grew up in classical music backgrounds where you had to challenge for
first chair saxophone every six,
eight months you gotta go to the conductor and say,
I want for his chair.
And if you're a first chair and he thinks I have a shy,
he's going to come over to Joyce's Roth's talking bout you.
Oh,
you both,
you both get to play this piece front of the orchestra next Wednesday.
You best practice.
Ah,
okay.
And we'll both get up and we'll both play 18 bars of the same piece and there
just may be a switch in front of 120 people,
all of them colleagues.
All right.
We learned from the music school,
you know,
the racy stuff was big band.
All right.
If you're in terms of,
you know,
uh,
we played rocket role in parallel,
but big band,
it's got a square vibe to it because it wound up in elevators in restaurants and
whatever.
But they had cut and contests and there was nothing more cut.
And then Benny Goodman versus chick Webb,
big band at Roseland ballroom,
that shit is on.
People would bet on it.
They would play the same four songs.
You play your version of it and we'll play ours.
Wow.
Yeah.
Throw down a big Pan,
throw down.
Oh yeah.
And it was furious shit too.
You know,
it wasn't like friendly.
They would say dancers would stand in the middle of those sparks and that's
where you get that.
Yeah.
He's postures that stuff like this.
Okay.
And the dancers were competing.
The Lindy hoppers could be,
wow,
Frankie,
you know,
all these guys throw it.
Um,
so it was competitive and we learn that's how you do it.
You know,
my two mentors in,
um,
uh,
music or,
first and second chair clarinet,
the La Philharmonic,
and he comes from that
also.
You know,
you have a whole different vibe that,
uh,
I'll take a grateful dead approach,
which is the complete opposite of that competition,
man.
Leave that at home.
Yeah.
You know,
well,
we're here to celebrate and so,
and I completely understand that's where I'll go after work,
take my vest off.
But my goodness,
dad,
he took a totally different turn,
right?
They said,
go ahead,
take all of our shows.
Come on,
you know,
sell food in the parking lot,
man.
We had to,
when we,
or we didn't eat boxing for money,
it's different than boxing for fun.
Right,
right.
Learn that very early and we learned it through music.
Yeah.
You know,
some of the folks learn it in the rank.
Other folks learn it in their first few days in a law firm or,
and they join a team.
It's interesting the way you described it with music,
because I tried to explain that to comedians.
I say,
think about how much time a musician has to spend practicing and how little we
spend practicing.
We are practices in front of the audience.
For the most part,
it's a simplified version of the 10 big apartment.
A simplified version of the how many hours rule is the 10,000 hours you've heard
about it?
Yes.
That's a very simplified version.
Okay.
That's digestible.
10,000 hours.
I don't know.
You break that down.
Was it take a six years,
maybe something like this.
The True Asian paradigm is 10 hours a day.
Every single day for 10 years.
If you have a little,
a little kid and he's got to have heart surgery,
you want that guy,
right?
It's right around 30,000 hours.
If you're going to go flying in a helicopter over New York,
Shitty,
you want Captain Paulie?
Tremonti it's about 40,000 hours.
Okay.
Uh,
my dentist Doctor Glassman who teaches is a 40,000 hour man.
Okay?
Uh,
so if you ever crash or get pelted gimme a call,
I will hook you up.
It's about 30,000 hours in.
That's 10 hours a day.
Every single day for 10 years.
And that's what creates,
uh,
a jet pilot,
a great surgeon,
a great writer,
you know,
anything in the arts and letters.
That's,
that's the architect.
Unless you're out prodigy and g if you bundle that and typing it's tragedy very
easily.
So yeah,
prodigies and tragedies often go hand in hand.
That's something about people that get things very easily that for whatever
reason it slips through their fingers more quickly as well.
When my shift and my dad was an eye surgeon,
okay,
did well and uh,
uh,
when my sisters,
wanting to go to college,
he said,
I think that's a great idea.
And made her pay for it.
Oh,
she wouldn't value it if she didn't pay for it herself.
It's probably right.
I signed my first contract when I was $1,350 stereo and a three records.
I worked all summer shoveling shit at the local a horse stable.
It's where I learned Spanish.
I don't know that you got it.
Do that.
You learned the same thing from sports.
Yeah.
Your kids do sports.
Which ones?
Um,
martial arts.
And,
uh,
one of them is really into gymnastics.
Yeah.
Are they competitive in it or are they,
do they enjoy themselves?
Are they on team,
like they're unturned tournaments or,
and is that something that
the get go here,
I'll back up.
I'm leading up to something.
Can you guess?
I think you always are folks.
Folks are starting to recognize certain traits in me as in I really like the
getting ready more than the actual show.
Really.
You actual show I'm making fun here and be a poetic,
the Monitor blows the guitar players pissed
the spotlights on the wrong guy.
I have a cold but that six months,
six weeks leading up to it.
I remember the rehearsal we did it if it's thing and hey,
when we recorded the track over that they remember when we got measured for the
shoes that fucking oh it was great and it's,
where did we eat after that?
I got to go back there and Andy,
Andy,
Andy.
Yeah.
I always sought to make those rehearsals and whatever as memorable as possible
because you didn't do a whole lot more.
I getting ready.
Then Yara throwing the punch.
Yeah.
Ask anybody on one of your shows.
Yes.
Yeah.
You have such a great insight for that though.
You know,
some people,
they eat meat.
Even if they're aware of it,
they're not consciously aware of it.
They're not focusing on all these details.
The getting ready.
He's as much of a,
if the band says they don't like rehearsing,
you're doing it wrong.
Hey Man.
It's like if you're sitting on your laurels,
you're wearing them on the wrong part of your body.
First off,
where are you rehearsing?
Right?
As in Miami?
No.
Where are you training?
Hawaii.
Cleveland.
Okay.
Let's talk,
because even in Cleveland,
you can turn it into your place.
Do you follow?
What is your routine you follow?
What music did you listen to?
You dig?
How did you warm up?
Simple,
simple things.
You know,
most people are feared,
terrified of singing when they go in to sing it.
Now I don't care who it is.
The first verse is always a little tight.
In the second verse is a little better.
Why?
Because they didn't warm up.
Right.
All right.
And the idea of we'll go in and sing along with a dozen of your favorite songs,
puts your head gear on,
get the reverb to Santa for me.
That starts with Motown.
I'm a sole growler.
I'm the,
I'm closer to Wilson picket.
Then the guy in the rolling stones,
that was loud.
I don't know what that sounds like on the headphones.
You know,
that's,
I spent many.
I'm going to put the headphones on here.
There we go.
Now Babe.
Yeah,
that's right.
I started sounding like that when I was 12.
I started practicing that when I was 12.
I started imitating the persuasions,
Jerry Butler to singer.
Um,
let us 13,
much to the cantors,
Chagrin in Hebrew school.
Okay.
Again,
parallel existences.
You know,
I'm Jewish,
but we always walked around with little buttons back then and said,
never again.
I'm a combat hippie.
Peace,
love,
and heavy weapons.
Some people don't believe you.
Sometimes you got to get insistent.